what do you think the rock told us
wrestling buddies back in the day do you
think he was like alright I'm gonna quit
wrestling so I could do movies like the
Tooth Fairy in Journey - did you laugh
now but it's gonna be awesome
okay jabronis journey to the mysterious
island
so journey to follows this teenager who
has major teenage angst who wants to
find him a serious Island because he's a
big jules verne fan he's a vernian as
they call him and the rock plays his
mom's dude and he's all like oh no
you're not my dad hello ever he gets a
message from someone on the mysterious
island so he has to go check it out the
rocks like yeah that'll be fine our
bonding time between us dudes it'll get
me in with the mom more and moms love
that
and so they hitch a ride with Luis
Guzman and his fine-ass daughter played
by Vanessa Hudgens which you know she's
hot yeah she is then they go down at the
mysterious island where things just
don't make sense and now we have our
movie iswe went into this movie thinking
that this movie was gonna be complete
dog turns out it's not complete dog
I mean it has it stuff where adults
are gonna be like that makes no sense
whatsoever that's just stupid but it has
this cool fun mystery adventure element
to it too it's not like Spy Kids 4 Rose
like spike it's 4 is good for absolutely
nobody who lives mysterious island is
good for kids although adults are gonna
be like when okay let the kids okay
there are three kinds of kids movies in
the world kids movies like spike is for
they're good for nothing they're good
for nobody they're they shouldn't have
happened in movies like Spy Kids 1 and
what I remember anyway I might be taking
a leap it's been a while since I've seen
that I remember it being good for kids
you know point is those kids movies that
kids can watch and adults can be like
cool my kid can watch that I can go do
it I can play poker with the guys and
then there's the lion Kings and the toy
stories where it's just good for
everybody and everyone loves them and
they're like these religious experiences
and it's just great and worth it
mysterious islands not that one it's
it's the middle one I mean you have
flying bees you have adventure it's
almost like at a point this movie was
like yeah we are ridiculous let's bounce
cherries off the rocks packs it was
stupid but at a point I was like at
least they know it's stupid then you
realize they're trying to just show off
3d and then you hate it a little more so
as a kids movie it works for kids you
can be like all right kids go watch
journey - I'm gonna go watch chronicler
with a grey or something in the end I
will say it's a good time if you're
drunk
or you're a kid yeah
knob rattles it sounded like drunk
Gollum it didn't so that was supposed to
sound like a kid I think Gerber baby I
think that voice it's that's not that's
not good it's not healthy and stick
around cuz I got a couple cool things
for you guys you know I wouldn't give
you something if it wasn't awesome this
coming week I'm gonna call it you
reviewers movie awards week because the
you reviewers movie awards is coming out
this coming week like four days from now
on the 15th it premieres on en TV so
check out Ian's TV subscribe to them so
you don't miss the you reviewers movie
awards it's on the 15th 16th 17th and
18th of this month I know it's not one
show four times it's four parts of the
show subscribe check it out 15th of this
month you reviewers movie awards
they're coming like OMA and while I was
down there I met the lovely female me
Kathryn Reitman yeah she's sexy
she was like well you're here so let's
film some breaking it down so I broke it
down with Kathryn reitman the new videos
up go check that out it's hilarious not
just hilarious because I'm in it and
she's in it and you know we mesh and we
have great chemistry because we're us
but it just genuinely is funny and
awesome so check that out subscribe to
her because she's sexy and talented I
gotta say antenna funny there's drama
there's comedy there's murder you guys
will love it who's there for you bring
it in bring it that's right hug your
screen bring it in I'm there for you so
in any case if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]